honorable guests ladies and gentlemen
saving our planet lifting people out of
poverty
advancing economic growth these are one
and the same fight the most peaceful
and wholehearted various in this fight
are teachers worldwide who ignite
students educate and inspire
the next generation to rise to the
challenge
this year the 2020 global teacher prize
goes to one of these peaceful areas
let me congratulate mr ranjitsin
tisar from india for winning the global
teacher prize
mr gizelle's father inspired him to
attend teachers college
ranjitsin managed to bring his i.t
knowledge into school and particularly
supported girls
who could not go to school for months of
lockdown
due to a local terror attack
thanks to his digital learning
innovations
the students could still access all
teaching materials with qr codes
vanjin's story is testimony
that the best teachers combine their
knowledge
strength and great spirit to help
those most urgent in need
let me therefore congratulate mr
ranjitsen desal
on his victory and thank all the
teachers
worldwide for their tireless work
which continues to be ever more
important
in times of confident isolation hardship
and turmoil please
shine on thank you